Professor Charles
Bailyn: Just in time for our
last class, we get this in
yesterday's New York
Times, and all over the rest
of the media.
"New Planet Could Be
Earth-like."
You know, every time they get a
new planet, it's always
Earth-like, but this one might
really be true.
It was found by the standard
Doppler shift method,
which you guys all remember,
and turns out to be the lowest
mass planet that's been
discovered in that particular
way.
And so, as a kind of final
farewell calculation,
I thought we'd check the New
York Times' numbers on this.
You can go back and read the
article for yourself.
The information given there is
that the orbital period is about
13 days.
The distance between the planet
and its star – that's the
semi-major axis – is given as
7 million miles.
These are, of course,
not the world's best set of
units.
The distance to the system is
20 light-years.
That's really close.
Somebody's quoted in the
article as saying,
you know, we could go there.
Not so much.
And I looked up the apparent
magnitude of this star,
which turns out to be about
10.5.
And so, what can we do with
information of this kind?
Well, let's first put this into
some kind of sane set of units,
here.
Thirteen days is--let's see.
Three days is--3.5 days would
be 1% of a year.
So, this is,
like, 3 x 10^(-2) of a year.
Seven million miles.
That's something like 10
million kilometers,
10^(7) kilometers,
which is 10^(10) meters.
So, that's something like 7 x
10^(-2) Astronomical Units.
And you know right away what to
do with that,
or, at least,
you will if you go back in your
notes for a few months.
This is in good units to use
a^(3) = P^(2)
M.
M, then,
shows up in solar masses.
So let's figure out the mass of
this star.
Let's see, (7 x 10^(-2))^(3) /
(3 x 10^(-2))^(2).
That'll be the mass in solar
masses.
7 x 7 = 50, times 7 is 350,
times 10^(-6) over 10 x 10^(-4)
[(350 x 10^(-8)) / (10 x
10^(-4))].
That's 35 x 10^(-2).
.35, which is 1/3.
Okay?
So, this star is 1/3 of the
mass of Sun--perfectly
respectable mass for a star to
be.
And then--let's see.
Let's do something else.
It's 20 light-years away.
Twenty light years,
that's something like 6
parsecs.
So, it's really nearby,
as these things go.
Not that you would want to take
a spaceship and go there or
anything, but it is one of the
closer stars.
And then, we can do this thing.
We can figure out the absolute
magnitude of this star.
I've written down the apparent
magnitude.
So, that's that equation.
Let's see.
5 log (6/10).
Let's call that 2 x 3 x
10^(-1), yeah?
That's 6/10 - five.
And then, you know,
this thing about logs,
if you multiply them inside the
bracket, you can add them
outside the bracket.
So, this is log of 2,
plus log of 3,
plus log of 10^(-1).
Log of 10^(-1) is -1,
and the other two,
I happen to know.
The log of 2 is .3.
The log of 3 is .5.
Minus one, that's 5 x -.2 = -1.
And so, 10.5 minus the absolute
magnitude would be -1.
Let's see.
How's this going to work?
This has to go over there.
That has to come over here.
Absolute magnitude, 11.5.
Now, you may remember that the
Sun has a magnitude--an absolute
magnitude of around 5.
So, this is much,
much fainter than the Sun.
That's good,
because it's less massive than
the Sun, and low mass stars get
faint really quickly.
How much fainter?
Well, we know how to do that,
right?
Let's see, that looks--in the
easiest format,
it looks like this:
M_star -
M_sun =
b_star /
b_sun.
This a minus sign out here in
front?
Yes.
So, that's 10^(-2/5 (11.5 -
5)), which is equal to
10^((-2/5)(6.5)).
All right, what are we going to
do about that?
6.5 over – 65/5 = 13.
So, this is 10^(-1.3 x 2).
2.6.
You could work it out.
And that, in turn,
is equal to--remember,
this is b_star
/ b_sun,
brightness of the star over
brightness of the Sun.
That's 10^(0.4) x 10^(-3);
3+; 3 + .4; - 2.6 and that's
– oh, I don't know,
what, 2.5 at a guess,
times 10^(-3).
A tiny fraction of the
brightness of the Sun.
Less than 1% as bright as the
Sun.
And this is the importance of
the discovery.
Because it's in a 13-day orbit.
It's really quite close to the
star.
We figured out how close.
It's 7%.
The distance of the Earth to
the Sun is this planet from its
star.
But the star is much fainter
too.
And so, if you do the little
calculation, which is quite
straightforward to do – we
won't do it here – of how much
energy this planet receives from
its star,
compared to the amount of
energy that the Earth receives
from the Sun,
you get almost exactly the same
answer.
So, here is a planet whose
surface temperature is likely to
be quite similar to that of
Earth.
Here is a planet where liquid
water could exist.
Now, we don't actually know
that much about this planet
except for its mass.
It's five times the mass of the
Sun--sorry, five times the mass
of the Earth.
That could be either a big
Earth or a small Neptune,
and those are quite different
objects.
And we don't really know what
category, from that point of
view, it's in.
It seems unlikely that it would
be a big Earth,
because this is a low-mass
star.
It's also, as it turns out,
a low-metallicity star.
So, it's got only 1/3 the stuff
of the Sun, and it's got less
than 1/2 the frequency of heavy
materials as the Sun.
And so, it's hard to imagine it
could build up a rocky planet
five times bigger than the
Earth, but you never know.
Stranger things than that have
happened, and will probably
happen again,
in astronomy.
So, you don't know what will
happen with this one.
There's rumors going around,
I should say,
that there are even more
entertaining planets going to be
announced in the next few weeks,
so, keep your eye on the
newspapers.
There may, in fact,
be more to come.
Okay, so that's the last
calculation, here.
You just never know when these
things will show up in the
newspaper.
Okay.
What we're going to do on
Monday and Tuesday,
we're going to do this double
strength section--sorry?
Monday and Wednesday.
Thank you.
We decided not to do the
Tuesday one.
We've got you guys all
sectioned.
I think there was an email
yesterday, which told you what
section you're in.
If you have any problems with
that, you know,
make sure we know about it in
advance.
And later, well,
probably Saturday,
or so, I will post three pages
of instructions.
You don't have to read them
particularly carefully,
but I would like you to
download them and print them and
to bring them with you to the
class.
Let me take you through the
first page of this.
Here we go.
Cosmology: The Game.
And let me just take you
through the sequence of play,
so you know approximately what
will happen.
So, at the start of the game,
everybody gets a role.
You can be a junior or a senior
scientist at one of several
competing scientific
institutions,
or a member of the review
committee that decides which
projects to do.
Each of the competing
institution then proposes a
project and a funding request.
The senior scientist has to
present the case.
The review committee then gets
to decide.
And so, you can't do all of
them.
You can only do some of them.
So, the review committee
decides what projects to approve
and they give either partial or
a full funding,
and then, they report why they
have made the decisions they
make.
And then, we tell you what the
results of that scientific
exploration is.
So, you know,
you go out and you try and find
more supernovae and we tell you
that--I don't know what happens.
Magically, all the supernovae
have disappeared,
or they're all way,
way, way too bright,
or whatever it is that the
answer turns out to be.
And then, you know a little bit
more about the Universe.
At that point,
the review committee,
which is made up of aging
pundits, all die off.
The senior scientists are
promoted to the review
committee.
The junior scientists are
promoted to senior scientists,
and the review committee are
reborn as junior scientists,
or something like that.
And so, we sort of cycle
through all the roles.
And you keep going through
these cycles until you figure
out what the dark matter and
what the dark energy is.
And then, at the end,
we will sort of debrief,
and decide what the key moment
of discovery was,
and award a suitable simulation
of the Nobel Prize.
It was M&Ms last year,
but we'll see.
So, that's approximately what's
going to happen.
And the key thing is what kind
of projects can you propose?
And the other two pages of this
handout are going to be a list
of potential projects that you
can propose.
You can also propose anything
else you can think of,
and we will invent results on
the spot for any other kinds of
projects that get approved as
well.
But I figured it would be a
good idea for you to have,
at least, a range of
possibilities of things you
might consider proposing,
and why.
So, that will be posted on
Saturday.
My experience is that in just
under two hours,
you can figure out all the
secrets of the Universe in this
particular--well,
of a Universe that I design,
which is, you know,
not as sophisticated,
perhaps,
as the real Universe will turn
out to be.
Okay, procedural questions on
any of that?
Yes?
Student: So,
the Universe that we're looking
at isn't going to be like the
actual Universe as an exercise?
Professor Charles
Bailyn: Who knows?
Since I don't know what the
actual Universe is,
it would be a little hard to
give you the actual Universe as
an exercise.
What I have done is I have
invented a Universe,
which is consistent with
everything we know now,
and has many more answers than
we know now.
I would be very,
very fortunate,
indeed, if that turned out to
have anything to do with the
real Universe.
So, I wish it were true that I
had those kinds of powers.
But it's possible.
That's the key.
Other questions?
Okay.
So, last time,
we ended on kind of an
optimistic note.
I had written down this plot,
which was a plot of
Ω_λ versus
Ω_m,
going from 0 to 1 and beyond.
And I put down--I showed you
the plot of three lines on this
plot, which is the lines
indicated by different kinds of
cosmological observations.
So, the supernovae,
which we've talked about a lot,
force you to be on a line
something like that in the plot.
So, this is where the
supernovae observation kind of
forces you to be.
And then, the observations of
the Cosmic Microwave Background
force the sum of these two
quantities to be one.
And so, you end up with
something that looks like that
from the Cosmic Microwave
Background.
And then, by comparing
simulations of the growth of
clustering to the actual
clusters of galaxies that we
observe in the Universe,
there turns out to be a third
line, and it looks like this.
So, this comes from clustering.
Is that legible?
Close enough.
Okay.
And so, the great thing about
this was, if you will recall,
that there were three different
lines on a two-dimensional
graph,
and they all cross at the same
point.
And this constitutes a test of
the theory, because it is not
necessarily true that if you put
down three lines at random in a
two-dimensional space that they
will all cross at the same
point.
And so, the fact that they do
makes you think that something
about how we understand what's
going on is going pretty much
right.
Because there's no reason for
these things to cross at a
point.
We predict that they do because
you know they're all measuring
the same Universe but in
different ways.
And so, the fact that they do
lend some credence to this whole
wonderful set of stories.
But there's another way of
looking at this plot,
which is to look at what these
axes are.
What are we actually plotting
on this plot?
This Ω that shows up is the
ratio of the density of
something to the critical
density of the Universe.
So, this axis is,
effectively,
the density of the dark matter.
And this axis,
here, is the density of the
dark energy.
So, what we are plotting in
this wonderful plot where
everything works out so nicely
is the density of something we
don't know anything about versus
the density of some other thing
that we don't know anything
about.
And so, in a certain sense,
the fact that we're
working--regardless of where the
lines are,
the fact that we've got these
two axes means we don't have any
idea what's going on.
So, that's perhaps the more
pessimistic view.
And, you know,
thinking about this,
you get a kind of faint odor of
epicycles.
Remember epicycles?
Epicycles, I talked about in
the very first class,
your very first lecture of this
class.
This is the business back in
the Middle Ages,
where they thought the Earth
was still the center of the
Universe,
and they were trying to figure
out what was going on with the
orbits of the planets.
And they discovered that a
single circle for each planet
didn't do the job.
It didn't concord with what the
observations were.
So, they said,
all right, well,
you know, the Earth's the
center of the Universe,
and we know everything has to
be a circle.
So, we'll put circles on top of
circles.
And then, they were able to
match the observations.
But then, the observations got
better and they had to have ever
more complicated circles on top
of circles.
So, let me--so,
that was the story of epicycles
back in the Middle Ages.
And then, of course,
what it turned out is that the
idea that the Earth was the
center of the Universe,
and the idea that everything
goes in circles is just wrong.
And as soon as you abandon
those two ideas,
and have the idea that the
planets go in ellipses around
the Sun,
all of a sudden,
everything gets much simpler
and it's all explained.
So, what's happening in
cosmology now?
We're observing the motions of
galaxies and of objects within
galaxies, like supernovae that
we can see.
And the first thing we found
out is that the rotation of
galaxies and other indicators of
matter aren't in accord with
what we expect,
so we invent dark matter to
explain the internal motions of
galaxies and galaxy clusters.
We then discover that the
external motion,
the motion of these things
through the Universe,
also doesn't accord with what
we would have expected,
so we invent dark energy in
order to explain that.
So, we've now,
in the past twenty-five years,
invented two different,
but completely imaginary,
as far as we know,
concepts, to fill 96% of the
Universe with,
to figure out what's going on
with the fact that the motions
we observe are not the motions
we expect.
How many more?
You know, let's go out and
measure some more things,
then maybe we'll need dark
something else.
And dark something else after
that.
And maybe it needs to change
with time.
And maybe it needs to magically
appear halfway through the
history of the Universe,
or something like that.
Who knows?
You know, if you keep inventing
these things,
of course, you can explain
anything you like,
just in exactly the same way
that if you have enough
epicycles, you can have a model
with the Earth at the center of
the Universe that explains all
the motions of the planets you
see.
If you get to just keep
inventing words here,
of course, you can explain the
Universe.
And, you know,
what would have happened if
this line didn't come across?
Supposing that line had been
out there.
What would you have done?
What you would have said is,
well, of course,
we don't understand dark
energy.
So, we've just proved that dark
energy varies with time,
or varies spatially,
or becomes opaque at large
distances, or some other
quality.
And then, we would have
rewritten this graph so that
they do cross.
That's not very compelling.
And indeed, it has gotten
sufficiently embarrassing that
there is now just beginning to
be a feeling that maybe what's
going on is we need new laws of
physics.
Maybe we're at a moment like
the end of the sixteenth
century, or the end of the
nineteenth century,
where the current basic ideas
that we base our theories of the
Universe on are about to be
radically transformed.
That's possible.
It's also possible that we'll
wake up three years from now and
see in the newspaper that
someone has discovered what the
dark matter is.
And that three years after
that, we will wake up and read
in the newspaper that some
scientists have developed a good
string theory that entirely
predicts exactly how the dark
energy is going to behave.
I think, in general,
it's always a good idea to bet
on standard physics,
rather than revolutionary,
new ideas.
But, if you keep at it for a
quarter of a century,
as we have, in looking for the
dark matter, and keep finding
nothing, you got to start to
wonder.
And indeed, there was a radical
theory, proposed a few years
back, about the dark matter in
particular, that there is no
dark matter.
It's just, we don't understand
the laws of gravity.
And so, you know,
we had to modify the laws of
gravity for very high
gravitational fields.
That turned out to be
relativity.
And they suggested that you
also need to modify the laws of
gravity for very low
gravitational fields--the kinds
of things you feel at the edge
of a galaxy, from the galaxy.
And they figured out how you
would have to do that in order
to explain the orbits of
galaxies without using any dark
matter.
This is called MOND,
for Modified Newtonian
Dynamics.
And I don't think that--it's
become clear that that
particular theory probably isn't
going to go anywhere,
for various reasons.
It doesn't seem to be
self-consistent.
But nevertheless,
this was seriously proposed.
It was also,
I have to say,
a little philosophically
dubious, because if you want a
new theory of gravity,
you don't want to go back to
Newton and start over again.
You probably want to start with
relativity and move on.
But they made it consistent
with relativity.
They worked out all the stuff
and it seemed to work okay,
except, it turns out,
it disagrees with observations,
also.
But it was a real attempt to
imagine that these things might
really turn out to be epicycles.
And if there isn't progress in
finding out what's going on,
I think we're going to see more
of that as time goes on.
And it may be that in fifty
years, these things will look
like what we think about people
who thought that the Earth was
the center of the Universe.
So, we'll see.
Now, there is one additional
thing that we know about the
Universe.
In addition to,
you know, these three lines,
which are kind of the basic
information that we currently
have.
And that is--so,
here's another fact about the
Universe, kind of an obvious
one.
The fact is that we exist.
Otherwise, we wouldn't be
having this conversation,
right?
And what does that tell you
about the Universe?
It tells you the fact that life
exists, and in particular,
what we grandiosely refer to as
intelligent life,
exists.
Let's see.
What do you require the
Universe to have if life is
going to exist?
It needs a couple of things.
We can get into a whole
argument about life as we know
it, and whether you can make it
out of silicon instead of out of
carbon,
or whether you can have life
made entirely out of neutrons on
the surface of a neutron star,
or something like that.
But no matter how you slice it,
it's got to have some
complexity to it.
You've got to have a lot of
moving parts one way or another.
You have to have information
flowing back and forth.
You can't make a living
creature out of nothing but
helium atoms.
Helium, you may remember from
chemistry, is a noble gas.
It doesn't interact.
It can't form structures.
And if you had nothing but
helium, there would certainly be
no life because there would just
be a bunch of helium atoms that
don't interact with each other.
If you made the Universe
entirely out of WIMPs,
Weakly Interacting Massive
Particles,
that just, kind of,
fly past each other and don't
pay any attention to each other,
you're not going to have
anything like life,
because there's no complexity.
It probably also needs some
time to evolve.
It took a while.
If you start--there's this
wonderful experiment where you
take a whole bunch of stuff that
was supposed to be in the oceans
of the early Earth.
And you put it in an atmosphere
of carbon dioxide,
and you keep sending
electricity through it,
simulating lightening strikes.
If you keep at that for long
enough, you can make things that
seem like some of the simpler
amino acids.
So, you just keep flashing
lightening at the ocean and you
hope that you eventually--you
build up life.
Maybe yes, maybe no.
But, certainly it takes a long
time.
And once you have somehow,
magically, out of this process
of self-replicating viruses or
something like that,
then, you got to stick around
for a few billion years while
evolution takes hold and makes
bigger and bigger and more and
more complex structures.
So, you have to have a certain
amount of time to allow this
process to go forward.
So, for example,
supposing it were true that
Ω_λ,
that's the density of the dark
energy, instead of being around
.7, was greater than 100.
So, the whole Universe is being
pushed apart by this stuff,
and there's hundreds of times
more of it than there is in the
current Universe.
You're not going to form any
structure.
We looked at the formation of
structure last time.
You just push the Universe
apart really fast,
and you never get galaxies,
or stars,
or anything like that,
because there's too much dark
energy to let them congeal.
So, push Universe apart--no
structure.
So, that would be a Universe
that's very unlikely to have any
kind of complexity and any kind
of life,
because you just take all these
individual particles and push
them far away from each other.
Supposing it were true that the
density of matter is
significantly less than 10^(-2).
So, instead of having 1/3 of
the critical density,
it has less than 1% of the
critical density.
Then, you've got nothing to
form the structures with.
And so, the same thing happens.
Also, no structure.
On the other hand,
if the matter density is way up
in the thousands or the millions
in this kind of scale,
then everything collapses right
away back into a black hole.
And again, there isn't a lot of
structure in a black hole.
It's one single point in the
center of the event horizon.
So, we have no way of knowing
what these numbers should be.
But what we do know is that we
are fortunate that they happen
to be in the relatively narrow
range, because if they weren't,
we wouldn't exist.
This turns out to be true of
most of the constants of nature.
For example,
here's another example:
the Schwarzschild radius.
Remember the Schwarzschild
radius?
The event horizon of a black
hole, given by 2GM /
c^(2).
Now, supposing you lived in a
Universe in which G,
the constant of gravity,
was substantially bigger than
it is in our Universe.
If G were bigger.
And supposing you--in that same
Universe, c, the speed of
light, were a good deal smaller
than it is in our Universe.
Just some other--pick some
other values out of a hat such
that this is true.
Then, the Schwarzschild radius
associated with any given mass
would be bigger,
because both G is
bigger, c is bigger,
and then, for the same amount
of mass,
you get a big Schwarzschild
radius.
So, now, think about what
happens if the Schwarzschild
radius is bigger than the radius
of a white dwarf.
Then, you never get white
dwarfs from neutron stars.
All stars evolve when they run
out of nuclear fuel straight
into black holes.
All stars end as black holes.
And the consequence of that is
that the carbon that is made in
stars is never dispersed into
the Universe,
and you never end up with
planets.
Because the next generation of
stars is still made out of pure
hydrogen and helium,
just like the first generation
of stars was.
And you never end up with
enough heavy elements--with any
heavy elements.
And so, you can't form planets.
So, no carbon,
or anything other than hydrogen
and helium.
And you're not going to make
life out of hydrogen gas and
helium.
Now, carbon of course,
this fabulous substance,
does all this wonderful
chemistry.
It forms rings.
Does all this great stuff.
That's why organic chemistry,
which is the chemistry of
carbon, is more complicated than
the whole rest of all the other
elements--chemistry of all the
other elements put together.
And so, the properties of
carbon are very,
very important for allowing
complex structures to exist.
So, properties of carbon.
And it turns out that if you
vary--would disappear,
or not be able to support these
complex chains and complex
carbon chemistry,
would disappear if the
constants of nature,
and in particular,
something called the fine
structure constant,
was even slightly different.
It also turns out you couldn't
make the carbon in the first
place, because there's a
property of the way the energy
levels work in an atom that
allows the reaction of three
helium atoms to fuse into a
carbon atom,
to occur fast enough for that
reaction to actually take place
by a substantial amount.
So, it wouldn't take much
messing around with the
constants of nature to make
carbon either not exist,
or have different kinds of
properties.
You know, if carbon turns out
to be just like iron,
and it just kind of sits there,
you're, again,
going to have some trouble
creating any kind of complex
life.
So, we have this odd situation,
in which it appears that
drastic, really quite drastic,
fine-tuning of natural
constants is a pre-requisite for
life.
So, not any set of constants
will do.
In fact, if you picked a random
bunch of numbers for all these
constants, almost certainly,
that would be a Universe with
no complexity in it at all.
And this gives rise to a set of
ideas called,
generally, the Anthropic
Principle,
which is kind of the idea that
the fact that life exists,
and people, in particular,
is important for understanding
physics--for understanding basic
physics.
And the way I've just stated
that, you know,
that seems kind of obvious,
right?
Of course, it has to be true
that the Universe is such that
we can exist,
because we know we exist,
and we're the ones who are
studying the Universe.
And so, just in that form,
it's not very interesting.
But the implications of it lead
you in a wide variety of
different philosophical
directions.
So, the question is:
why do all these constants,
G, c,
λ, what have you,
have the values they do?
Okay.
So, as I said,
there are a wide variety of
different kinds of categories of
answers to this.
One is that it's just a big
accident.
You know, whatever it was that
set these numbers happened to
pick a set of numbers that
allowed life to exist,
and there's nothing to talk
about because it's just a
complete accident.
And it could just as easily
have picked out some other
numbers.
And even though most sets of
numbers don't allow for the
existence of life,
the one that's--the set of
numbers that were somehow
determined by whatever mechanism
determined,
just kind of by accident,
produced a set of numbers that
allows complexity to exist.
Not very satisfying approach
because, among other things,
if that's true,
your thinking stops dead right
at that point.
If you can attribute everything
to accident, you know,
you just go on with your life.
Another, sort of the opposite
of this, is to say it happened
on purpose.
Life was created,
if you want to use that term,
or the constants of nature that
allow life to exist,
are created on purpose.
And there is an obvious
religious sub-category here,
where you say that there is a
Creator, a god of some kind,
who did this on purpose.
So, this leads to various kinds
of religious explanations.
But in more general terms--and
it doesn't have to be religious.
This is what's called the
Strong Anthropic Principle,
which says that for some
reason,
be it religion or anything
else, that the Universe must
have life, or have the set of
constants that allows life to
exist.
You know, one of the things
that the physicists are trying
to do is to figure out why these
numbers have the values they do.
Maybe, it turns out that if you
finally work out the final
theory of physics and
everything, that will tell you
what these numbers have to be.
And there's only one choice
that you can't choose randomly
from these numbers,
that there's some theory that
underlies, that requires you to
pick certain numbers,
and that those numbers in turn
require the existence of life.
And whether or not you
attribute that to religious
causes, it doesn't make a
difference to the sort of
structure of this kind of
argument,
that there's only way you could
have made the Universe.
Somebody phrased this,
it might have been Einstein,
I don't remember,
phrased it as:
the question is,
did God have a choice?
Could you have made a
self-consistent Universe with
some other set of numbers?
Maybe not.
But the version--the approach
to this, which is getting the
most attention at the moment by
the kinds of people who think
about these things,
is the concept of the
multiverse.
Universe is one Universe.
Multiverse is many.
So, the idea is that there are
many Universes with different
sets of constants,
sets of numbers.
Numbers and laws.
Well, if that's true,
then, things are pretty
straightforward.
If you've got 100 jillion
Universes out there,
and each one has different set
of laws,
a different manifestation of
the laws of nature,
then, it's not surprising that
the one we live in happens to be
conducive for our existence,
because there's a whole bunch
of other ones out there that
there are no people in.
And naturally,
we exist in the one case where
we can.
You know how this works.
It's like going out into a
parking lot, and you see a
license plate out in the parking
lot.
And the license plate is 308
BJ6, or something like that.
And you say,
gosh, what a coincidence.
Out of all the license plates
in the Universe,
that one happens to be sitting
right in front of my office.
But, of course,
if it was any other license
plate, you would have said the
same thing.
And so, that's actually not
surprising.
So, similarly,
if you have a whole lot of
cars--of Universes in the world,
if you have--there are a whole
lot of cars in the world,
right?
There's billions of cars in the
world.
What are the odds that you get
into the one you own?
Well, pretty high, right?
Because you're doing it on
purpose.
Similarly, if there's lots and
lots of different Universes,
each one with a different set
of physics,
what are the odds that we exist
in one that allows us to exist?
Pretty high.
But the question is,
"Where do all these Universes
come from?"
And so, how do you generate
many different Universes?
Why wouldn't you be satisfied
with just having the one you've
got?
And so, again,
there are a number of different
sub-categories,
here.
There's the one in which you
look beyond the cosmic horizon.
Now, the cosmic horizon--you
know, if the Universe is 13.7
billion years old,
we can't see anything more than
13.7 billion light years away.
And, in fact,
the further away we look--we
look back in time,
so, we certainly don't know
anything about what something
13--what about something 15
billion light years away is
doing now.
And so, you can imagine that
there are kind of slow changes
in the constants and laws of
nature,
and that by the time you're 100
billion light years away from
us, that part of the Universe,
which is causally disconnected
from our own,
has some other kind of physics
that is going on.
And so, you postulate an
infinite Universe of which we
can only detect ever,
in principle,
a tiny fraction.
And over there,
somewhere, there's another set
of constants going on.
And so, there's another set of
physics far away that we know
nothing about.
So that's one option.
Another option is other
dimensions.
Those of you who have read any
of the popular accounts of
string theory may be aware that
one of the problems,
or perhaps, advantages--well,
the computer scientists call
these features,
of string theory,
is that you require either nine
or ten, or eleven,
or perhaps twenty-six spatial
dimensions,
in order to make it work out.
Then, they do this clever thing
where they say,
of course, we live in a
three-dimensional Universe,
but it's really a
ten-dimensional Universe with
seven dimensions rolled up so
tight you can't see them.
Kind of a dubious proposition,
but it works out--it actually
works out quite well,
mathematically.
But you could imagine that
you're in a two-dimensional
Universe.
And here's your Universe,
but it's embedded inside some
additional spatial dimension.
There could be another
two-dimensional Universe down
here, and you would have no way
of interacting with it.
And so, you can imagine that
these extra dimensions that are
being postulated allow the
existence of many different
three-dimensional Universes,
kind of, next to each other,
spread out in these higher
dimensions.
And perhaps they don't all have
to be three-dimensional
Universes.
They can be other kinds.
I mean, that's another crucial
number, right--is how many
spatial dimensions your Universe
has.
And so, one could imagine that
these kinds of extra dimensions,
talked about quite seriously by
the strength theorists,
allow the existence of many
different Universes with
different physical laws to
choose from.
There's also a kind of
evolutionary argument.
This is presented in a popular
book by a guy named Lee Smolin,
which is a wonderful book.
I want you to read it.
His thought is that each
time--and this came up,
I think, earlier in the class.
Each time you make a black hole
inside the event horizon,
a new Universe forms.
So, that's one way of doing
this.
So, new Universes form from old
ones, from black holes,
or whatever.
And supposing you postulate
that each daughter Universe has
slightly different parameters,
but only slightly different,
from its parent,
in the way that each of us has
genetic material that's closely
related,
but not identical to that of
each of our parents.
Well, what happens?
You, then, favor--in the idea
that you may come out of black
holes-- you favor Universes that
produce lots of black holes.
And so, there's a kind of
survival of the fittest--not
just for organisms,
but for whole Universes.
If you're the kind of Universe
that produces lots of black
holes, you're going to have lots
of children.
Then, after this goes on for a
long time, most of the Universes
in the multiverse will be the
kinds of Universes that produce
lots of black holes.
How do you make black holes?
You make the most black holes
by producing lots and lots and
lots of stars.
Stars are complex objects.
This is the kind of Universe
that you're likely to end up
with life in.
And so Smolin's argument is
that because of this survival of
the fittest for Universes as a
whole,
you're almost guaranteed that
any particular Universe you pick
out is the kind of Universe that
will produce lots of black
holes,
and therefore,
lots of complexity,
will support life.
And there are various other
versions of this same kind of
thing.
And this is an attempt to,
kind of, use the biological
arguments for how you get
complexity on a cosmological
scale.
There's a difference, of course.
In the case of biology,
we get to go back and look at
the fossil record,
and we also understand
genetics,
so that we know how the small
modifications are created.
I mean, you need a set of
physical laws,
here, that tell you how
different one Universe is from
its parents.
And of course,
that is not something we have
any understanding of,
or knowledge of.
And this whole multiverse
concept is now getting a lot of
attention from the people who
worry about the philosophy of
physics.
And one of the arguments that
people get into over this kind
of thing, which is kind of an
interesting one--people spend a
lot of time that--people worry
about this spend a lot of time
worrying about,
is this science?
Smolin, by the way,
thinks it is.
He thinks that his idea of
these black holes makes a
testable prediction--namely,
that the current Universe
should be one that produces the
most number of black holes of
any possible Universe.
So, if you imagine changing the
constants of nature and doing a
big simulation of what the
Universe would look like with
that,
then any other set of constants
of nature would produce fewer
black holes than this Universe
does.
I think that's actually
problematic, because most stars
in our Universe don't produce
black holes.
So, you can think,
well, tweak it up so that they
all make black holes.
He then argues that that same
tweak changes star formation in
such a way that you actually get
fewer stars to work with in the
first place.
Maybe so.
Other people argue that this is
totally not science,
because as soon as you are
invoking Universes other than
our own,
you've left the realm of
science, by definition.
Because, what is the definition
of science?
It's studying our own Universe
in ways that you can actually
test.
And, by definition,
if you're talking about another
Universe, it can't be tested.
So, this isn't science.
Other people say, well, look.
Supposing you have some kind of
a theory which predicts things
in our own Universe,
which you can observe,
and also, the same theory
predicts things about the
multiverse, which you can't
observe.
If you observe the things in
our Universe that you can
predict correctly,
then,
that gives you some confidence
that the rest of the theory
might also be right.
And so, this is a sort of
intermediate case,
where it's mostly science,
perhaps.
I have to say,
I, personally,
think it's the wrong question.
Because both sides of this
argument presuppose the idea
that if it's science,
that's good,
and that if it isn't science,
you shouldn't be talking about
it.
Right?
I think that's a problematic
point of view.
Just between you,
me, and the video camera back
there, it's just not true that
things that aren't science
aren't worth thinking about.
There's plenty of things that
are worth thinking about that
aren't science.
And my own personal view of
this argument is that this is
one of them--that this really
isn't science.
But I don't care if it's
science or not,
because it's still pretty
interesting.
And I think we should also keep
in mind that the border of what
science is and isn't has evolved
rather quickly over the past 100
years,
and this ought to be apparent
from what we've talked about in
this course.
Twenty years ago,
talking about planets around
other stars was complete science
fiction.
They did it on Star Trek,
but not in the scientific
journals.
And this has,
now, as we saw from the example
this morning,
changed really,
very dramatically.
Forty years ago,
the idea that you would have
black holes to actually look at,
that you could pour gas into
them to see what happens,
was equally unscientific.
A hundred years ago,
the idea that you could say
anything scientific about the
Universe as a whole was
completely preposterous.
That was part of philosophy,
not part of science.
And yet, over time,
all of these things have been
kind of assimilated into
science,
and there's no reason to think
that the kinds of philosophical
musings about the multiverse
might not also,
in some way that we can't
currently understand,
be pulled into science.
And so, this whole argument
over whether this is science or
not might be overtaken by
events.
And events are,
after all, moving pretty
rapidly these days.
This is a golden age of
astrophysics because of the
instruments we have,
the techniques we've developed,
the theories we have.
You know, historians of science
a thousand years from now will
say, the beginning of the
twenty-first century,
that's when it was all
discovered.
And so, it's kind of a
privilege for me to play some
small role in this,
and to have the opportunity to
talk to you guys about it.
And so, I would say,
whether or not you've learned
anything interesting about
astrophysics,
and whether or not you've
learned anything useful about
the way science works,
if you've acquired even a
fraction of the enthusiasm that
I feel for this enterprise,
then, I think our time together
has been more or less
worthwhile.
And so, that's all I have to
say.
Thank you for your attention,
and we will meet next week.